[Música]
su ciudad cambió de manera significativa
francesco passerini es el alcalde de
codogno el epicentro europeo del
coronavirus venir aquí sigue siendo muy
conmovedor para mí mostrar un año
después de la primera alerta inauguró
este monumento dedicado a las víctimas
de la ciudad en marzo de 2020 la tasa de
mortalidad se multiplicó por 5 aquí
queríamos representar la fuerza de una
comunidad unida ante un enemigo
desconocido que hizo estragos en nuestro
territorio terrible que ya estaba
enterado eso parecía imposible lejos de
las grandes puertas hace imposible
lontano de grandes parte de las
metrópolis
la noche del 20 de febrero de 2020 aún
está grabada en su memoria a las 11 de
la noche recibió una llamada del
prefecto me dijo que en el hospital de
colonia se había identificado el primer
caso de coronavirus
[Aplausos]
había se me eriza la piel cuando me
acuerdo fue un momento unos segundos
alucinantes aún no le pasan mil ideas
por la cabeza de todo uno trata de
digerir el asunto de recibir el golpe a
las siete de la mañana había convocado
al consejo y decidí emitir la orden que
confinaría a mi ciudad
una decisión radical totalmente inédita
así esperaba poder evitar la saturación
de las salas de urgencias
el hospital es civil de codo no fue aquí
donde empezó la pesadilla
la doctora laura rice but y lo recuerda
muy bien
me encontraba ante un paciente joven
cuyo estado de salud estaba perfecto
tres días antes pero se agravó muy
rápido
cuando llegó le dábamos dos litros de
oxígeno y cuando lo lleve a reanimación
le dábamos 14 litros con el tanque los
protocolos clásicos no dan ninguna
explicación
todas las pruebas habituales salen
negativas sólo queda una posibilidad el
nuevo virus chino cuando llegó el
resultado de la prueba cuando me
llamaron estaba aterrorizada y llena de
angustia sentía angustia por la
situación general pensé ya está lo que
vamos a hacer y sentía anunció también
por mí directamente porque atendía a ese
paciente tenía miedo de haber contagiado
a sus familiares
una nueva enfermedad de la que no sabía
nada rápidamente las hospitalizaciones
aumentaron la médica fue de las primeras
en enfermarse se recuperó y volvió a su
cargo su compromiso le valió la medalla
al mérito nacional todavía me cuesta
creerlo
incluso cuando abro la caja me siento
muy honrada ahora hay zonas cerradas
dedicadas a los pacientes con kobe
actualmente son la mitad de lo que eran
hace un año y el objetivo de la
vacunación es mantener esta reducción de
las cifras en este gimnasio de colonia
christina dragón y coordina la
administración de las dosis adecuada y
me acuerdo de los momentos en los que
todo estaba vacío cuando teníamos miedo
o ve a cabo para las ambulancias las
sirenas de las ambulancias me marcaron
ante césar y master entró había tantas
eran demasiadas tantísimo teníamos miedo
de no lograrlo
yo me acababa de tener un bebé y tenía
miedo de no poder darle
luego me contagió de kobe y sentía un
miedo entonces hoy en día vivir
participar en esta experiencia de león
es como ver un poco de una mente de
primaria de un divino
ella está inmunizada al igual que el
personal esencial de los profesionales
de la salud los primeros expuestos al
coronavirus es la primera dosis
entonces extienda su brazo izquierdo por
favor en su sector hay 240 mil
habitantes por vacunar un tercio de
ellos ya recibió su primera dosis a
finales de abril buenos días
disculpe buenos días quisiera saber
cuándo voy a poder tener la posibilidad
de ser vacunado cuántos años tiene nací
en 1973
de acuerdo todavía no es posible pero
más o menos en un mes deberíamos poder
vacunar a las personas de su edad
está bien muchas gracias hasta luego
hasta pronto
desde febrero de 2020 antonio fazió ha
perdido todos sus puntos de referencia
es verdad que fuimos los primeros
entonces creo que tenemos un poco más de
un miedo que los demás ahora ninguna
acción cotidiana es trivial para este
traductor de origen belga ni siquiera ir
a hacer sus compras fuimos muy muy
rápido antes de subirse al carro un poco
de desinfectante en las manos por qué o
por qué toque cosas que todo el mundo
también toco
de regreso a su casa desinfecta cada una
de las cosas que compro
en realidad hay un riesgo de contagio en
los objetos es como si pudiera ver las
manchas con luz ultravioletas aparecido
a veces pienso que estoy exagerando
pero por otro lado por ahora no hay otra
opción
esta amenaza invisible lo angustia hasta
el punto de llevarlo a contactar a una
psicológica por primera vez en su vida
buenos días
buenos días mi coleta
cómo estás
estoy bien esta situación nos quitó
nuestros puntos de referencia todo lo
que estábamos acostumbrados
estas conversaciones semanales le han
permitido volver a cruzar de nuevo las
puertas de una farmacia son pequeñas
victorias que se convierten en grandes
victorias es verdad que para mí la
farmacia era uno de los centros de kobe
y ella fue la que me dijo anda y verás
es una ayuda invaluable un progreso he
hecho de pequeños pasos hay uno grande
que él cuadragenario quisiera dar
realmente me gustaría poder estar
vacunado lo más pronto posible para
poder recuperar un poco de mi libertad
la inmunidad es también el objetivo del
alcalde de co2
porque aislar una ciudad entera tiene su
precio es difícil de evaluar a nivel
local pero para toda la zona roja los
primeros 15 días nos costaron más de 100
millones de euros
es nuestro soldado monstruoso
hoy debe asegurar la continuidad de los
servicios municipales y sigue gastando
los fondos para la actividad comercial
la policía las casas de retiro en un año
la ciudad ha tenido tres confinamientos
y la misma cantidad de reapertura por
oleadas un yoyó sanitario que ha puesto
a los comerciantes en una situación
insostenible y entre los primeros están
los propietarios de restaurantes o la de
mi me das un café en el café de emiliano
free solar y todo cambio actualmente
tiene cinco empleados llegaron las
cervezas y el vino y también el té verde
les redujo la jornada laboral y los pone
a cargo de asegurar el servicio por
turnos de medio tiempo un mediodía a la
vez hoy nicoletta está en el mostrador
aquí está el magneto trabajamos poco
afortunadamente mi jefe siempre me ha
garantizado un salario constante
[Música]
yo logré sobrevivir porque vivo con mis
padres si no sería un gran problema lo
suficiente para poder mantenerse a flote
sobrevivir solo con las ventas de comida
para llevar
la empresa no genera suficientes
ganancias volvemos a abrir del todo o
nos morimos de hambre ya no podemos
seguir dependiendo de las ayudas
públicas la situación es insostenible
el jefe todavía tiene un poco de
esperanza en un futuro mejor
un futuro que también se escribe entre
las paredes del colegio
[Música]
buenos días valentina gambarini dirige
el liceo de codogno después de varios
meses de cierre total en 2020 los
alumnos han podido regresar de manera
progresiva desde septiembre fue fácil
hacerlo
[Música]
no porque constantemente debo controlar
la situación con mis colaboradores para
que los estudiantes respeten las medidas
pero debo decir que se portan bastante
bien que los llamados de atención son
escasos
son maduros y han entendido la
responsabilidad que tienen horarios
adaptados corredores señalizados
productos de desinfección o puestos a
disposición de garante de la educación
la directora pasó a ser responsable de
la salud de sus alumnos todo bien por
aquí si estoy viendo si los jóvenes
están bien formados en fila mantengan la
distancia por favor
[Música]
actualmente un puerto de las clases
todavía se realiza de manera virtual
durante varios meses la escuela a
distancia era la regla para todos algo
por lo que se pagó un alto precio en
relación con el año pasado el porcentaje
de deserción escolar se duplicó
estos jóvenes estuvieron encerrados en
la casa no crean que aprovecharon para
irse de fiesta la mayoría de estos
adolescentes vivieron un largo periodo
de entierro
y este aislamiento generó una regresión
que hizo nacer miedos modificó las
relaciones en el seno de la familia
juliá de 18 años y clara de 19 nunca
habían estado tan contentos de ir al
colegio con el colegio de distancia no
podíamos ver a nuestros amigos ni a los
profesores antes de febrero de 2020 no
me había dado cuenta de la importancia
del colegio con las paredes de su cuarto
como único horizonte cuando el colegio
estaba cerrado se modificó su relación
con el tiempo cuando uno se queda en la
casa los días siempre son iguales el
tiempo no pasa en ese momento se siente
largo pero cuando uno se detiene tiene
la impresión de que el tiempo volver
porque todo es igual no pasa nada nuevo
nada interesante entonces me pareció
realmente rápido
en tiempos normales a los 18 años uno va
a los bares se encuentra con mucha gente
y puede enamorarse
y yo ya llevo un año encerrada en mi
casa entonces no he tenido muchos
encuentros además de los que ocurren por
internet y eso claramente no es lo mismo
las redes sociales son el salvavidas al
cual esta generación pudo aferrarse
machado
julian se confinó en twitter ahí empezó
a escribir su diario de confinamiento
desde el primer día
no nos imaginábamos que ese sería el
último día de nuestro año escolar el
cuento que volví del colegio y luego al
día siguiente era mi cumpleaños
winnie podios pigatto que explicó que
estaba asustada que no entendía lo que
estaba pasando afuera y al día siguiente
del anuncio del confinamiento cumplió 17
años en vez de la fiesta
la estudiante recibió una ola de
mensajes cariñosos y desde ese día en el
que tuve mucho éxito empecé a contar
cómo era la vida diaria en la zona roja
fue increíble lo que pasó no esperaba
llegar a tener 14.000 seguidores una
ventana hacia el exterior cuando toda la
ciudad estaba aislada del mundo en la
casa de retiro los 139 residentes se
vieron privados de cualquier visita de
sus familiares durante casi un año
y listo vamos a ver a su querida hija
ya llegamos significara por el otro lado
es la primera vez que jean carla puede
volver a ver a su hija vilma en 13 meses
buenos días estoy muy emocionada me lo
imagino
[Música]
que me voy a aprovechar
i
para poder estar tan cerca madre e hija
deben tener esta barrera de plástico
tienen las manos calientes mira nada más
tienes dos pares de guantes sí sí tengo
los guantes mira tengo una primera capa
aquí y esta segunda aquí como es porque
hacemos todo lo posible para que estés
bien protegida para que estemos
protegidas para que nada esté
contaminado una gran protección
justificada por la viralidad de la
enfermedad que aquí se llevó la vida de
30 residentes ahora puedo abrazarla
tocarla
está bien está igual de hermosa que
siempre con sus 89 años quisiera volver
a la casa quien no un deseo todavía
imposible mientras que toda la población
no está inmunizada
está bien pero
pero sería mejor si pudiéramos estar
todavía más cerca
pero esto me alegra me conformé amor
entonces como le fue bien está contenta
ven a darme un abrazo mamá adiós mamá
adiós
estos encuentros son una primera
victoria un paso hacia el regreso a la
normalidad
algo que todos aquí desean